Good morning John!
So I have good news, and I have bad news.
I actually have lots of good news and a little
bit of bad news. And the first bit of good
news is that I did the bad news in my last
video. So if you want bad news, go watch that
video.
On to more good news; George Watsky, I accept
your challenge that wasn't intended to be
a challenge.
Gotta be the one to bite the bullet
I'm sinner but I bet I coulda been a better
man
I wanna be zen, but I go sipping on some medicine
instead of meditating but I get when I can
I don't wanna wind up in the gutter with a
bottle of malt-liquor, bitter cause I never
got a call
Telling me
That it's all
Figured out
I'm sick of doubt
But I'm looking at the wall
Part of me was hoping to be caught up in good
in the God in me
But I got a lobotomy gotta get that I oughtta
geta-
DANG IT!I fail your challenge.
If you don't know what I'm talking about,
you should click.
More good news: if you would, please go to
this website I know of called google.com and
in google.com type i s space h. I'm frickin'
awesome.
And then if you type in "Is hank green space"
you get a ton of amazing things that people
are wondering whether I am, including if I'm
gay unfortunately, that one some how slipped
in.
But people are also curious if I'm Batman,
and so I figure I'll take these off and I'll
put this on... Uh, so what do you think? Batman?
No, not really? You're not seeing it?
Maybe I should talk like this.
More good news! This map, shown here, is an
extremely detailed view of the twelve colonies
of Battlestar Galactica and how they can all
exist within one star system. It's possible,
because it is a quaternary star system; two
binary star systems orbiting each other. Fascinating!
Aah, the mysteries that our galaxy must contain!
I should make a video about the James Webb
Space Telescope which is going to help us
know more. And it's awesome, and amazing.
Though this obvious desire at the beginning
of Battlestar Galactica for it to be hard
science fiction really makes me feel even
more disappointed by the stupid ending to
that series! Jeez!
I have to go to the doctor now, so lets talk
about this at the, at the doctor's office.
So science fiction and fantasy take up the
same space in the book store and they take
up the same space on my bookshelf. So I do
agree that they have many things in common,
but I have a very specific rule when it comes
to science fiction and fantasy. If you, as
a writer, are introducing me to a fantasy
world then you are free to define that world
in whatever way that you choose and to solve
internal conflict in whatever way you see
fit. But if you're introducing me to a science
fiction story, where the reality of the book
is based on the reality of reality, you cannot,
and this is a law, you cannot solve the internal
conflict with made up, glow-y holes in the
ground like they did in Lost. In short, fantasy
can contain science fiction, science fiction
cannot contain fantasy.
It's boring in here.
More good news!
Apriso, which is a manageable facsimile of
Asacol, the drug that I need to take that
costs six hundred dollars now, just sent me
this card in the mail that says I pay no more
than twenty five dollars for my Apriso except
unless I have to pay more than seventy five
dollars which I do because it's like two hundred
dollars so this is a lie! But it's still less
than six hundred dollars. Why does it say
"pay no more than twenty five dollars" when
I still have to pay, like, one hundred and
fifty. That's more than twenty five dollars.
That is a bugger of an asterisk right there.
More good news; today we are officially launching
Vidcon, and some of you will find that laughable
because people found our website a long time
ago. But it is officially online now--vidcon2011.com
It is in Los Angeles at the same hotel that
it was at last year, the Hyatt Regency Century
Plaza. July twenty eighth, a Thursday, is
going to be an industry specific day, and
then the twenty ninth and thirtieth, Friday
and Saturday, are gonna be frickin amazing
fun party adventure community times. Frickin
amazing fun party adventure community times,
what more could you ask for?
And to register for the conference and to
find all the information that you need go
to vidcon2011.com
Okay now the final piece of good news is for
the people who follow me on twitter and are
very curious about the two truths and a lie
that I did yesterday that I did not inform
them which one the lie was.
So, two truths and a lie.
One: I just found my first gray hair.
Two: I used to play the trombone in high school.
Or three: I'm a closet Alan Jackson fan.
Click down here to find out if you are wrong!
John, I will see you tomorrow.